This video is brought to you by keeps wisecrack. What's you guess,
cute to watch this video,
it will fill you with a tiny morsel of knowledge and broaden your horizons.
So take your mind off the job off your schoolwork,
off your life and succumb to our hypnotizing logo, because let's be honest.
What else is there to do right now?
What's up wisecrack Jared, here today,
we're going to dive into the work of one very controversial filmmaker.
Paul Verhoeven for Hoban's films have divided critics,
some call him misogynistic kitschy, and statistic. Others.
Call him a brilliantly subversive satirist. So,
which is it to find out let's explore for Whovians,
most divisive films to see if his work is as deep as his champions claim or as
dumb as his detractors to cry.
Welcome to this wisecrack edition on Paul Verhoeven, deep or dung,
and as always spoilers ahead. But before we continue,
I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor keeps it may be really embarrassing to talk about,
but if you're worried about losing your hair, you're not alone. In fact,
it's probably everyone's fear who could pull off a bald head like Dwayne Johnson
or VIN.
And the unfortunate part is that two out of every three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness. By the time they're 35,
luckily keeps is an FDA approved treatment plan for keeping the hair on your
head with keeps you meet with the doctor online, receive a treatment plan,
tailored to your needs and get medication shipped right to your door.
Keeps offers prescription and over-the-counter medication.
And has doctors on staff to keep track of your progress with keeps some men even
experienced hair regrowth,
find out why keeps us over 1005 star reviews by going to
keeps.com/wisecrack. When you click the link in the description,
you'll get 50% off your first three months. So check it out today.
And now back to the show for Homans had a controversial career from the get-go.
He began in the 1970s as a mainstream filmmaker in his native Holland making
provocative work that combined highbrow melodrama with Frank depictions of sex
and violence. However,
by the eighties for Hoban's films were condemned by his government for being too
violent, perverted and decadent, and for not having an explicit message,
unable to find financing.
The Dutch filmmaker took his talents to America where ironically,
he would face these exact same criticisms.
His American films generally fit into two camps, violence filled action,
spectacle, and sexually explicit dramas with Robocop,
total recall and Starship troopers for Hoeven injected,
a scifi sensibility into traditional action, film formulas, a revenge thriller,
a spy adventure, a war film. And of course it's all incredibly violent.
And when I say violent, I mean, this.
[Inaudible].
For Hoven did the same with his dramas, but instead of explicit violence,
there was explicit sex and nudity.
Just look at how much we had to sensor the Showgirls clip and the feedback not
great.
One review of total recall called a dumber than WWF wrestling and innocent of
hypocrisy about it's cartoon violence. As for Starship troopers,
the Washington post said it was exactly like star Wars.
If you subtract a good story, sympathetic characters, intelligence, wits,
and moral purpose. And in Showgirls case,
the Austin Chronicle said it was so shabbily built that it must've been a
cynical desire to cash in on the Publix per Venus.
Now Verhoeven undeniably loves depicting excessive sex and violence,
but is that all there is to his work or are the critics missing something
as with most filmmakers understanding Verhoeven's intentions is helpful in
discipling his work. Ironically,
the man who was driven out of the Netherlands for being too extreme was shocked
by American culture to quote for Hoven, perhaps I was naive,
but when I arrived in America, I was amazed.
I was curious about the things that were shown on television and in cinemas and
having not been in the U S for that long,
I was able to distance myself and look at American culture in an ironic way,
perhaps in reaction to America's cultural access Verhoeven quickly embraced over
the top violence in his films. Take total recall on the surface,
the film appears to be just another big budget.
Arnold Schwartzenegger flick in which he offs countless goons and saves the day.
But for Hovan amps up the violence to ridiculous Heights.
When bullets hit people, they explode in grizzly bright red flourishes.
And it's not just the bad guys who die in glorious detail.
Innocent civilians are mowed down. Schwartzenegger even uses this one,
unlucky SAP as a meat shield,
the gunfire shredding his torso into pieces.
The brutality is so extreme that it becomes in and of itself.
The point transforming the film into subversive commentary on America's
fascination with why get ready for a surprise.
Indeed.
The absurd violence only highlights how nonsensical your typical action film
truly is a fact for Hogan himself acknowledged.
I have a feeling that making these kinds of idiotic things that his total recall
Robocop, Superman Spiderman, it's all completely nonsense in the film.
Douglas Quaid,
an ordinary construction worker undergoes a memory implant that allows him to
live out his dreams of being a secret agent on Mars. However,
during the procedure,
something goes wrong and Quaids previously suppressed memories come flooding
back,
suggesting that he really is a secret agent or Izzy total recall constantly
pokes holes in its so-called reality. When Kuwait goes for his memory implant,
the total recall rep tells him that for two weeks,
you will get to live out his secret agent. Fantasies.
People are trying to kill you left and right,
you meet this beautiful exotic woman. Go on.
I don't want to spoil it for you, Doug,
but you rest assured by the time the trip is over, you get the girl,
kill the bad guys and save the entire planet.
And this is exactly what plays out in the film word for word Quaid meets an
exotic woman, kills all the baddies and saves the planet.
And it all happens in 10 weeks.
What's more when the technician implants Quaid with his memory package,
he remarks that's a new one blue sky on Martin married long.
And how does total recall end with blue skies on Mars,
obviously by constantly questioning the very reality of total recall Verhoeven
draws attention to the unreality of the violence on screen.
If none of this is actually happening,
then you can't take any of the violence on screen. Seriously.
The violence almost becomes a joke as of highlighting how silly the traditional
American action film truly is.
But this is only the tip of the Verhoeven subversive iceberg.
The filmmakers protagonists all fit the same basic mold,
seemingly moral and upstanding citizens who turn into instruments of violence at
the drop of a hat and Robocop Murphy starts out as a loving family.
Well, my son, Jimmy watched this cop show, TJ laser,
and this laser guy does this. Every time he takes texts out a fat guy.
So naturally my kid thinks that a good cop should be.
Only to become a literal killing machine and Starship troopers,
a bunch of [inaudible] teenagers become bug killing tools of the government.
And in total recall a seemingly normal average, Joe becomes well,
Arnold Schwartzenegger per Hoven.
There's a point to all of this after what went on in the second world war,
and we saw what people were capable of doing to one another audiences simply
wouldn't buy the idea of perfect heroes anymore.
People all over the world were forced to realize they were no better than the
Germans and were capable of committing similar acts.
Similarly Verhoeven's films show how easily normal people just like everyday
Germans in world war II can be seduced to violence in Starship.
Troopers Rico rejects the advice of his father because you're going to Harvard
and that's the end of it.
He doesn't want to go to Harvard or take a vacation abroad to a peaceful planet.
Instead, Rico wants to join the Federation and kill a whole lot of bugs.
Similarly, in total recall Quaid longs to be more than just an average,
Joe stuck working a blue card.
Oh, job. Don't you understand?
I feel like it was meant for something more than this.
I wanted to do something with my life. I want to be somebody.
What he really wants is to get into the thick of the action on Mars,
a place of civil unrest and terrorism,
both Rico and Quade yearn for the excitement that only violence can provide the
exhilaration of killing alien scum on foreign soil or shooting up the batteries
on a covert spy mission. All these characters need is a little push,
a propaganda pamphlet,
a memory implant to instantly become the killing machines of their dreams in an
interview promoting total recall for Hogan set,
the film actually depicts his greatest fear to quote for Hoven.
Total recall for me, had to do with fear of psychosis.
It had to do with the fear of basic fear of myself.
The psychosis is a way my brains could go. When people who behave nice,
suddenly turn out to be monsters and criminals and kill you by showing how
quickly his characters can be drawn to brutality for Hoving comments on how we
as a society can also so easily be seduced by violence in the name of war
law and order, or even just because deep down we like it,
but that's not all Verhoeven.
Doesn't only use violence as a meta commentary on the absurd view of American
cinema or as a critique of human nature,
to really understand his deepest intentions.
We have to go all the way back to his childhood for Hoeven grew up in Nazi
occupied Holland, where he was exposed to unimaginable horror, bombings fires,
and mutilated bodies on the street to quote for Hoven.
I remember seeing dead people.
I remember when I was with my father being forced to walk past a group of Dutch
people who had been executed by the Germans in a reprisal,
but younger Hoban didn't realize the severity of what he was witnessing.
And instead detached himself from the violence later,
like in the experience to watching a movie and Rob van sheers biography on
Verhoeven,
the filmmaker recalls watching houses be blown up burning across the horizon.
He calls the experience less scary and more akin to watching a particularly
intense, special effect. Similarly,
each of her Hoban's characters detach themselves from the horrors happening
around them.
And every day I have to make decisions that spend hundreds of people like you to
their deaths.
We're hoping these films are filled with people.
Nonchalantly watching violence on screens.
Robocop constantly cuts the world news of oppressive governments and insurgency
only to cut to ads for a game about nuclear.
Red alert, red alert, right in total.
Quaid watches,
people being shot repeatedly on news while drinking his morning smoothie and
Starship troopers.
The news cavalierly shows gruesome images from ongoing war hell they're even
advertisements for live execution.
Execution. Tonight at six, all net all channels.
These films to pick the world totally desensitized to violence just as
five-year-old for Hogan was numb to the carnage. He witnessed in a Metta twist.
Verhoeven uses this detachment to indict us because who is more desensitized to
violence than an American audience, munching, popcorn,
laughing and cheering in a darkened theater.
As people are viciously killed on screen to quote for Hoven.
People love seeing violence and horrible things.
The human being is bad and he can't stand more than five minutes of happiness.
Put him in a dark theater and ask him to look at two hours of happiness and he'd
walk out or fall asleep. Just look at Starship troopers.
The film is framed as one long recruitment ad,
not for any of the characters in the movie, but for us, the viewer.
Join the mobile infantry and save the world service guaranteed citizenship.
In the film we watch as a bunch of beautiful carefree teenagers become gung-ho
soldiers. We cheer as Rico and Carmen shoot down a bunch of grotesque,
hideous bugs, save the day and still find love.
We're so busy applauding and laughing that we fail to notice that we're rooting
for the bad guys. The idea behind troopers, according to her Hoven,
was to create a story that seduced the audience on one level,
but then make it clear to the audience. What they're admiring was actually evil.
The troopers in the film are actually part of a fascist empire committing
genocide against an intelligent alien race Perver Hoven.
We wanted to do a double story,
a really wonderful adventure story about these young boys and girls fighting.
But we also wanted to show that these people are really in their heart without
knowing it are on their way to fashion.
By getting us to root for pseudo Nazis for Hoban implicates the audience in the
characters crimes. We just like Rico,
Carmen and friends are so easily seduced by flashy images that we don't ever
stop to think about their context. We're just cute.
Innocent sheep brainwashed by the deranged images of fascist violence up on the
screen.
A similar sentiment is seen in Robocop where the news shows constant images of
chaos and disorder that lead the characters and us yearning for some unfettered
crotch shooting streets.
Justice.
So Verhoeven is incredibly deep and the critics completely missed the point of
his work case clubs. Right? Okay. We know,
we know we still haven't addressed the elephant in the room, a movie.
So reviled at one, the Razzie for worst picture, a movie so bad.
Even the people who like it tend to do so, ironically, yes.
I can only be talking about the one, the only Showgirls.
Okay. But here's the thing.
Show girls actually isn't that far off from Verhoeven's previous films,
just as the director critiqued a violent action films and Showgirls,
the filmmaker goes even broader turning his sights on the entertainment industry
as a whole Showgirls is the quintessential rags to riches Hollywood story,
a woman with nothing to her name works her way up to become a star.
This is the same story. Every Hollywood want to be dreams about move to LA,
make it big in the movies and become famous except in Showgirls for Hoban shows
how rotten the stream truly is instead of centering his film around Hollywood
for Hoven transplants, this narrative to the glitzy artificial Las Vegas.
And instead of making it big in the movies,
Nomi works her way up from dancer to background show girl to star show girl.
But all that glitters is not a golden nipple.
Tassel Verhoeven makes sure that no me's ascent is anything but glamorous.
In fact,
there's hardly any difference between the low-level strip club where Nomi starts
out and the flashy high-end Las Vegas showroom, where she ascends to stardom,
both places are driven by the same Craven,
commerce sex as Verhoeven puts it with Showgirls.
The attack on Vegas for example,
was that everything is bottom line and that sexuality is only another thing you
can sell for the highest price.
Everything in Showgirls is a sexual transaction from the driver who picks Nomi
up, expecting a little something in return.
You can sit a little bit closer if you want to the man who pays Nomi $500 for a
lap dance to the boss who Nomi sleeps with an order to secure a role as her,
our tribal crystal says.
Darlin, no, I'm not. We all are. We take the cash.
We cash the check. We show them what they want us.
But Nomi constantly tries to fight this commodification,
insisting that she won't sell her body. But by the end of the film,
she realizes the truth that her dream job becoming the star of a Vegas show is
yet another exploitation of sexual transaction.
The face is going to be a bumpy porch.
You're going to make a lot of money for the Stardust.
Whether she's dancing at the strip club or posing on a giant billboard it's
Nomi's body, that's making her money faced with such a realization,
Nomi spits and Zach's face and walks away the show as for the actual commerce of
the film for Hoven lampoons,
our cultural obsession with sex just as he did with violence by gratuitously
going over the top. So over the top,
in fact that we can't show you the scene where Nomi gyrates around to an
absurdly comical degree here, the sex, just like the Gore in total recall,
and Starship troopers becomes designed to incite laughter it too is a part of
the joke. And every aspect of Showgirls is in on this joke,
the films excessive over the top style is used to Lampoon the quintessential
golden age Hollywood musicals.
But while old Hollywood had lavishly choreographed,
classy song and dance numbers, Showgirls has lavishly choreographed buck naked,
gyrating that again, we can't show you what's more.
It mocks the competitive dog, eat dog nature,
ubiquitous and films about big Hollywood dreams. By again,
taking the genre to absurd extremes in a conversation between rivals,
Nomi and crystal. They bond over both enjoying dog food. Growing up literalized,
the two as dogs fighting over the same bone.
I used to love doggy chow, doggy chat too.
Who is the ultimate target of this joke yet? Again, it's us.
We are the audience at the cheetah lounge who can look but never touch.
We who pay money to see the same recycled Hollywood stories over and over again.
We who can't help,
but vicariously get off on the wanton violence and sex depicted on screen.
When the lights dim, finally, we can indulge in our true debased selves.
So we're going to give her Hoban's work or at least this portion of his work,
a certified wisecrack deep with no reservations.
But what do you think wisecrack is for Hoven brilliantly roasting our gluttonous
desire to consume outrageously graphic material,
or we try and way too hard to justify watching this.
[Inaudible].
Let us know in the comments big thanks to our patrons for supporting the channel
and our podcasts.
Don't forget to hit that subscribe button as always catch you next time guys.
[Inaudible].